can you tell us a little bit about what
happened with Troy Davis and and how
that influenced you yes so Troy Davis
was a black man executed in Georgia on
September 21st 2011 and leading up to
his execution hundreds of thousands of
people around the world were protesting
against his execution including a
handful of retired wardens and directors
of Corrections and so at the time I knew
nothing about the prison system I knew I
never thought twice about capital
punishment but the protests were so kind
of potent and it really kind of
galvanized me politically and so the
morning after Troy Davis was executed I
was feeling frustration and anger and
sadness and I went back to a letter that
the retired wardens and directors of
Corrections had written to the governor
urging him to grant Troy clemency and
that letter spoke to not just Troy's
potential innocence but the emotional
and psychological consequences that
killing Troy would have on the prison
staff sanctioned to do so so as I was
feeling all of these emotions I just
kept thinking you know what must it be
like for your livelihood to be tied to
the taking of human life and that was
really the seed that sparked clemency
and one of the things I found
fascinating because I think if you look
at mainstream media when you see prison
shows wardens tend to be white they tend
to be male but that's actually not the
case is it no I mean in Ohio the
majority of the wardens that I met
throughout the state were black women
you know and and most of the Alfre and I
went to Ohio in January before shooting
and we we spoke with a handful of
wardens and corrections staff and most
of the people that we spoke to or black
women and so it's just representational
II we see something very different yeah
oldest I want to talk about this scene
that I believe you shot five days into
the 17 days total for this 17 days shoot
yeah yeah take a minute for that
[Applause]
so five days in is the scene where you
decide if anyone's gonna take your life
it's gonna be you can you talk a little
bit about shooting that particular scene
oh yeah sure
hello everybody so yeah we did 17 days
all of my work was completed within five
days right
yeah it's called preparation that scene
in particular for me was sort of having
to explore the idea of the value of the
true value of life because you know he's
sitting there as someone is literally
saying this is how I'm going to take
your life these are your last precious
moments and these it calls to mind the
idea of what we take for granted in so
many ways that we don't even realize you
know so for for me I wanted to explore
what that was through Anthony's eyes
through his emotions and as you you know
saw he's not saying anything
he's has to process this whole idea of
his own personal value at least that was
the process for me and I thought it was
really a beautiful scene beautifully
executed one of my favorite scenes that
I've ever been able to perform just
because of how much it meant and the
challenge of trying to say so much
without having to say anything at all
and I thought it was a really sort of
smartly executed because it takes us all
a minute to just sit and be quiet and
think about what is the real value here
in terms of the daily lives we lead what
is the real value of the freedom that we
have that we may not you know fully
engage in a fully take advantage of you
know so I thought it was wonderful and
then of course in order for me to really
pull out that sort of performance I had
to rely on these two queens right here I
you know Chenoa I trusted you fully you
know say look you got it we're gonna get
it all right if you good we good and
then also pulling that emotion that for
me was you know sort of playing
ping-pong back and forth with with
Alfred just being able to work off her
how she was given that energy what she
was giving to me in that moment is what
I had to use to find those moments of
levity and then find those deeper
moments so it really was a team effort
that entire scene and I thank y'all for
that Richard what's interesting to me
about this film is that this is of
course a film about capital punishment
but it's also a film about the choices
you make in your life as you get down a
certain Road we think about can I do
this anymore which we saw play out in
both of your characters and can you just
I mean it's interesting because as an
actor it's one of the few professions
that hopefully it doesn't get so taxing
that you could keep doing it forever but
you could see as being this lawyer and
doing the work that he would do that it
would hit a point where it's a little
bit too much that scene about the baby
lawyer and the snapchat can can you talk
about working through the baby lawyer in
the snapchat scene man you know to see
can you just talk about that you know
playing the emotions of trying to figure
out what you're doing in that later
chapter of your life yeah I can try I
the thing that was interesting about
this character was as I think about it
now is is his own kind of death you know
I mean this movies really about the
collateral damage and the real damage of
the choice of killing someone and and
and this character I've been fascinated
with people who devote their lives in
this case to a to to work where if you
lose the the guy dies if you don't win
if you play a game of chess and if you
lose someone dies that's a tough that's
a tough life and I looked at him like he
was already kind of dying from from just
doing this and I remember that scene we
shot at the bar and I
who can barely look at Alfre and I
noticed that that she probably needed
some kind of connection or at least
that's what I felt and I just I just
couldn't you know I mean it was it was a
disdain for her because she represented
my life you know what I mean
so that's that's what was kind of
kicking around and felt he felt a little
bit like emotionally you know the scenes
with this lovely gentleman is amazing
actor you know when he when he had hope
he's expressed such great hope for my
ability to do something and it was it
just killed me it just killed me every
time I felt the hope you know it
surprised me and killed me what is
interesting because I think in a simpler
version of this story your character
would be the really good guy and
Bernardine would be the bad guy but I
don't think that anybody could walk away
from this feeling like Bernardin can you
talk a little bit Alfre about how you
came to understood why mean as you
mentioned that she wasn't necessarily
beating up bunnies as a kid so why do
you think she did this and did it make
you feel at all differently about the
people who do this work well that was
one of the reasons one of the great
benefits of acting is that you the
requirement is that you never stop
learning every time you you approach
them work you've got to learn about
somebody else's life everything their
history their the Anthropology of their
communities all of that because your job
is to leave yourself behind you the way
you speak though your gait your opinions
the way you see the world and just find
that person find the human being and
tell the story looking out from their
eyes and so that's that's beautiful and
so everything I needed was meeting those
women because I had no idea what that's
like I'm on the petition
side don't put Tookie Williams to death
Stanley Tookie Williams that we executed
here in California so but then that's
not my job as the artists or as the
actor so I see I believe them it's like
we need warriors we need them I'm a
pacifist but I understand that but I
know that I can't put myself in that in
that position because I am too emotional
that's why we do this work and I admired
their ability to stay balanced and to
say no sorry your mom's dead but you
can't go because if you let one person
do something it was really understanding
a job understanding a point of view that
is not mine that I will forever sort of
campaign against but it doesn't make it
right or wrong it's just you know the
necessity so yes I I get them I
understand it I understand how important
order is when you're walking around in
those in in the prison's Chinoy and I
had the privilege of spending time with
two condemned men besides the staff and
it is a world it is farther away from my
life than I've ever traveled and I've
done working in squatter camps and
refugee camp but and it's right there
and we pay for it so that's what we do
we go to be a witness to bring back what
we've witnessed and and then you do
however whatever you do with it because
everybody comes to this the way they
come to any other story or experience
with their own history so our job is is
not to do anything other than to try to
reveal what we feel as best we can the
truth of a situation of a reality I
think so for my use thanks everyone so
my now